Joe Biden's EV Obsession getting slapped
across the face with a hard dose of
reality one of America's biggest rental
car companies hurts trying to sell
20,000 electric cars from its Fleet and
pump that money back into the good
oldfashioned gas guzzlers making this
green energy fail all the more hilarious
is that just months ago the White House
is bragging how Herz was accelerating
the EV transition but it's not all that
surprising why Herz is doing this you're
more likely to see Greg play center for
the Lakers and you are to find one of
these dang EV Chargers Biden got
billions to Shell out on him he built
zero zero mayor Pete however isn't ready
to give up on the EV
dream I take very personally the
importance of the fact that America led
the world in the automotive Revolution
now that we are in the midst of the
second Automotive Revolution it is
critical that America do so once
more he just bored me to death death in
5 seconds yeah now you know what we feel
Greg I guess the truth hurts o oh good
night everybody can I leave early you
know here's the deal the rental car by
its very nature is supposed to be
punished by its user you pay insurance
for it you do whatever you want to it
it's not the reverse we don't take on
special responsibilities with the rental
car it's supposed to make our lives
easier and you don't put Commerce before
technology it's great to innovate it's
great to corre create but you don't
throw out your old coat until you got a
better warmer one this issue has been
driven by activism and wishful thinking
and some profit and it far exceeded the
infrastructure and the capabilities of
the industry itself so and also you have
the media that bought into the climate
science which wasn't real so what you're
seeing in Germany they're now forced to
use less less electricity now than they
did in the 1970s because they phased out
a basic need on the false presumption
that something would take its place they
were wrong it's stupid and I say this
app plotting electric vehicles because
some are impeccably designed but they're
a supplement to the existing gas
vehicles because it's impossible right
now then for to handle the load uh I
think you know these watching
politicians trying to ban gas powered
cars knowing that it's impossible and
what it's going to do to the American
hardworking citizens is cruel the
putting the cart before the horsepower
uh but they're willing to punish you
because they are impervious to the
hardships uh Dana so Herz is um I guess
it's a little embarrassing do you think
the White House is conscious that this
is even happening do you remember when
we did the story about how all the car
dealerships had all the extra inventory
of EES and they couldn't sell them and
the White House had the audacity to say
the car dealers are wrong right as if
they don't want to make money of course
they want to make money and sell these
cars Dan Santa said something the other
night about this whole thing he said we
do have market-based solar and it's a
compliment but we cannot walk away from
reliable energy that sounds like a
reasonable thing like why wouldn't the
left say okay actually that makes a lot
of sense the administration needs to
build so many charging stations to meet
their goals you I got this from the
automakers today they would need to do
414 Chargers would need to be installed
every day for the next seven years right
in order for them to keep up with the
demand plus it was not a good week for
the Biden administration's climate
agenda they got knocked back by the
fifth circuit on their whole dishwasher
plan to make you basically have no water
for your dishwasher and the washing
machines and the other thing is
consumers don't like it so instead of
putting money behind Innovation they're
trying to put the yes cart before the
horsepower that was a great line thank
you great line I have to give them that
do you have any great lines Harold Ford
Jr no so I think about I've been told
that at the beginning of the show J Jing
he's sensitive no they that's the last
thing I am the infrastructure for this
stuff is going to happen I remember when
we were making the transition remember
when you used to get in a car and the
seat belt would automatically come on
and no one wanted to wear the seat belt
now everyone wears a seat belt everyone
understands the reason the reasons
behind it I remember when we were trying
to transition in a public health
standpoint to no smoking in public
places and I said to I was in Congress I
said I can't imagine States like
Tennessee and North Carolina embracing
this and they have we've made this
transition this is a difficult and
different transition think about this we
produce more oil America in 2023 than we
ever have and I hope we continue to of
the next several years because the
transition is not going to I think
Democrats or Republicans or for that
matter activists who believe that we
somehow or another going to shun and
move away from oil and gas all together
over the next six months or 12 months
that's ludicrous what we should be
thinking about is how do we address some
of these issues one of the things that's
happened in the car business the cars
that sell the most are hybrids today uh
and the EV cars are not selling as much
largely because the infrastructure is
not there but I've been a believer when
when I first started doing shows on this
network the person that had me on the
most was Brett Bear and the person had
me on second most was Dana Pina when I
came on her show when often say the two
people in this country who are the
richest are investing in electric
vehicles and space exploration one's
name is Elon Musk and other his name is
Jeff Bezos uh we praise musk around his
table for his Innovation for helping to
make things faster cheaper help make us
healthier uh help things run more
efficiently uh he's still a believer
that this is the future and I happen to
believe that he's right but we're not
going to transition off of oil and gas
altogether this is a matrix in a more
balanced calibration that has to be
achiev over the next several years right
it can't be done through
mandates it's that's your takeaway that
was your takeaway okay it's the consumer
who will decide whether or not the
electric vehicles are going to be part
of the mainstream look the consumers
don't want it you when you have Herz
who's going to sell 20,000 vehicles at a
loss of of something like $250 million
of these electric vehicles because
people don't even want to rent them I
mean you've got a real problem and 57%
of the people in this country don't want
to buy them that's because they cost
over $50,000 each whereas your gas
vehicle the average price is
$30,000 and EVS in 21 22 and 23 79% of
them had more problems than vehicles
with combustible engines okay there are
problems the government set aside $7.5
billion doar for these charging stations
and there's not a one not a one has been
installed yet okay so I mean stop trying
to force us to do something we don't
want to do and I and I got to tell you
part of my resistance part of my anger
is because this battery is being made in
China all right while China's got these
Coal Fired plants and they are creating
all kinds of problems with the
environment we're giving them business
to create these batteries that no
insurance company wants to ensure that
when they when they die they're an
environmental problem and the American
people don't want the car the
manufacturers don't want to make the
cars Ford now is cutting back the
manufacturing of electric vehicles to
half of what they did and the bottom
line is the only people making money are
the people who are making the batteries
and that's China and let me just go a
little more on China just because I want
to on Monday this Administration decided
that Chinese Nationals coming across the
border instead of answering the 40
questions that everybody else has to
answer they only have to answer five
questions following the uptick in
Chinese Nationals okay I'm tired of
giving China the benefit of the doubt I
don't want to buy a car that they're
responsible for building and I and and I
think the American people agree and
that's it I'm going to get the judge in
EV for Christmas next year Christmas
pres Secret Santa just getting an EV not
from China though probably be less
expensive not from China not from China
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else